I just want you to know one thing
I'm not a monster
[Music]
I need you to be precise
tell me everything
yes
I don't know what happened I think you
fell off that hurt floor the windows
open
[Music]
that's why there's an investigation for
a more suspicious test because you were
the only person there
and of course you're his wife stop
I did not kill him
that's not divine
[Music]
you had a fight the day before he died
you need to start seeing yourself to
where others are going to perceive you
[Music]
is there anything that would seem
consistent with the suicide
you have to tell them exactly like you
remember it
you complain about the life that you
chose you are not a victim not at all be
fair I am a man who's been cheated on I
can't stand anymore
I'm innocent you know that right